meeting today today's virtual g7
ministerial wasn't the format we
envisioned for the meeting when we drew
it up but I'm glad we had the chance to
meet if only by teleconference I want to
thank the people in Pittsburgh for their
support and assistance in planning the
in-person event that we unfortunately
had to cancel certainly the most
pressing agenda item today was the Wuhan
virus something we're all committed to
fighting with transparency as is
necessary all around the world I made it
clear to our g7 partners especially to
our friends in Italy and the rest of
Europe that the United States remains
committed to assisting them in all ways
possible
this past Saturday the United States Air
Force sent a c-130 filled with medical
supplies to Italy the US military is
also finalizing plans to make some of
its excess medical equipment deployed
there available to our Italian friends
in addition our private businesses
scientific community NGOs and religious
organizations are answering the call to
health Samaritan's Purse
a private US charity set up a 68 bed
field hospital in Cremona a particularly
hard-hit city in northern Italy this is
the American people's famous generosity
at its finest
even as we spend substantial time on
working to figure out how we would fight
this virus together we're still keeping
our eye on the ball and the other great
challenges around the world which I've
grouped into categories first we spent a
substantial amount of time on threats
posed by authoritarian States the
Chinese Communist Party poses a
substantial threat to our health and way
of life as the Wuhan virus outbreak
clearly has demonstrated the CCP also
threatens to undermine the free and open
order that has underpinned our mutual
prosperity and safety in the g7
countries I urged every one of the
countries to work together to protect
the UN another organization from its
malign influence and authoritarianism we
g7 countries must promote our shared
values of freedom sovereignty good
governance transparency and
accountability and push the UN to uphold
these principles as well
group also spoke a great deal about
Russian holding and is accountable for
its aggression in Ukraine real progress
on eastern Ukraine must begin with
Russia honoring its commitments under
the Minsk agreements
I also reiterated the simple truth
Crimea is Ukraine the United States will
never recognize Russia's attempted
annexation we spent time to talking
about another group of challenges posed
by unlawful proliferation on Iran I
thanked countries for the regime holding
the regime accountable for the Millian
activity through actions like banning
Mahon air and designating all of
Hezbollah and other around back terror
groups as terrorist organizations our
pressure campaign remains designed to
induce a ran to act like a normal
country I urged our g7 partners to go
further in joining us and they should
have specially stand with the US and
ensuring that Iran never obtains a
nuclear weapon similarly the g7 and all
nations must remain united and calling
on North Korea to return to negotiations
and stay committed to applying
diplomatic and economic pressure over
its illegal nuclear and ballistic
missile programs another task before
that we discussed at length was to
resolve long-standing conflicts on
Afghanistan we discussed the peace
process I updated them on my recent
visit and how we can make intra afghan
negotiations truly successful we also
spent time discussing Syria where Russia
the Iranian regime Hezbollah and the
Assad regime are threatening Europe with
a humanitarian disaster in preventing a
political solution in accordance with UN
Security Council resolution 2254 we
spoke on Libya leaders there must
exercise restraint and deescalate and
reject toxic foreign interference and
engage seriously in UN mediated
discussions to determine Libya's future
and on Burma the group was united united
in support of Burma's democratic
transition economic reforms and efforts
to resist the malign influences Burma
must resolve the rakhine state crisis
ensuring and including justice for
victims of atrocities and accountability
for those responsible including senior
military
and finally we agreed to keep fighting
vigorously against terrorism terrorist
attacks by Isis like the one I opened my
conversation with today and al-qaeda are
increasing in the Sahel the region needs
better governance and burden-sharing
from our partners both in the region and
globally to restore peace and stability
signatories to the Algiers or Algiers
Accords were peace and reconciliation in
Mali must fully implement that agreement
even when we were unable to meet a
person we had a successful visit and the
Trump administration remains devoted to
our allies and partners and working with
them in these kinds of productive
multilateral formats without I'm happy
to take a few questions Thank You mr.
secretary
Oh following up on your comments today
but the g7 and looking ahead to the g20
talks virtually tomorrow that the Saudis
are hosting what is your message in
China is it time to cooperate with them
perhaps on the virus
or to confront them you mentioned that
the United States is committed to
assisting as g7 partners what about
China they've given lots of aid in terms
of masks etc around the world do you see
that as a positive do you see that as
something that we should be wary of and
with the u.s. itself be willing perhaps
to accept assistance Peter Navarro said
perhaps we would be good just follow up
in one point on that the German magazine
Der Spiegel was saying that at the g7
that he wanted them to use the term
Wuhan virus and that perhaps caused some
rift among the partners is that the case
and you believe that nomenclature is
that important that needs to be in an
international document Thanks
so let me take the first question to
begin with we've wanted to work with the
Chinese Communist Party throughout this
crisis this crisis that began in Wuhan
China
we tried you'll remember from the
opening days to get our scientists our
experts on the ground there so that we
could begin to assist in the global
response to what began there in China
but we weren't able to do that the
Chinese Communist Party wouldn't permit
that to happen
you'll recall - at the beginning of this
when it was clear that this was an issue
China knew about it they were the first
country to know about the risk to the
world
this virus and they repeatedly delight
sharing that information with the globe
so yes we we desperately want to work
with every country around the world this
is a global pandemic this is something
the United States wants to work with
every country including China to figure
out how to resolve to keep as many
people alive as many people as healthy
and then to restore our economies that
have been decimated by the Wuhan virus
so we are we are prepared to work with
them we're prepared to assist them we
want good things for the Chinese people
as well this this activity results in
the deaths of lots of people in China as
well it's not just been something that
is extraterritorial to China but it's
really important that we make sure we
get this right there was a lot of
discussion today amongst the g7 about
the intentional disinformation campaign
the China has been and continues to be
engaged in you see it you see it in the
social media you see it in remarks from
a senior people inside the Chinese
Communist Party talking about whether
this was a u.s. the u.s. brought to
China I mean this was crazy talk and
every member of the g7 today saw that
this is disinformation campaign China
now making small sales of product around
the world and claiming that they are now
the white hat in what has taken place
here this this isn't a time for blame
this is the time to solve this global
problem we're focused on that today it's
where the g7 members spent all of their
time but every one of the nations that
was at that meeting this morning was
deeply aware of the disinformation
campaign that the Chinese Communist
Party is engaged in to try and deflect
from what has really taken place here
and with respect to the statement I
always think about these meetings the
right answers to make sure we have the
same message coming out of it I'm
confident that when you hear the other
six foreign ministers speak they will
have a common understanding of what we
talked about today and we will talk
about the things that we have agreement
on and I'm sure low expressed a handful
of places like the jcpoa where we have
tactical differences about to achieve
our strategic outcomes make no mistake
about it everyone in that meeting this
morning was very focused on making sure
that we not only solved the health
crisis associated with the Wuhan virus
but also the economic
is the face the globe is we confronted
as well on Monday in your written
statement you said that the United
States would immediately reduce
assistance to Afghanistan by billion
dollars one what exactly are you cutting
to president Ghani this morning is
reported to have issued instructions to
his ministers of interior defense and
finance to cut their security budgets by
1 billion dollars total doesn't seem
like he's too worried about losing US
assistance what's your response to that
and 3 is the United States prepared to
proceed with its planned withdrawal of
troops from Afghanistan as long as the
Taliban honors its agreement not to
target US forces and to cut ties and
regardless whether the president Hani
and former chief executive Abdullah are
able to resolve their disputes over the
election they traveled to Afghanistan at
the time when there's not much travel
taking place for a very specific purpose
I went there to make sure that Afghan
leaders understood America's interest
there the role that all of the resolute
support mission has played there over
the years
and to urge them to execute on the
commitments that they had made in the
joint declaration that is the Afghan
leadership had made a set of commitments
things that they would live up to and so
far they have not executed and that I
went there to talk to them about how we
could assist them in delivering on that
I'll be honest it was very frustrating
there this political crisis that had
existed that I went there to try and
push forward to your point and the
statements that you just described I
haven't seen those statements we need
all of the political leadership in
Afghanistan to come together President
Ghani dr. Abdullah all of those who have
a shared interest in moving Afghanistan
forward in creating peace and
reconciliation for the Afghan people to
better the lives for Afghan people to
come up with 18
that can sit down and have conversations
broadly with all Afghan ease intra
Afghan ago she ations to resolve they
said about standing issues that is our
expectation for the Afghan leadership
it's why I went there is what I talked
about it's why we made the announcement
when we were unable to achieve that
during my meeting is why we made the
announcement that said the United States
is prepared to reduce security
assistance to them and we will continue
to try and convince all the parties the
Taliban including that it's time for
peace and reconciliation in Afghanistan
the US force posture that we've made
clear to all our partners we are going
to continue to evaluate that as we move
forward we have commitments as we
execute this plan we will watch the
conditions we've talked about this as a
conditions-based plan we will continue
to live up to those to make all the
parties live up to those conditions as
we work our way forward in the end
everyone understands and everybody that
I met with I met not only with President
Ghani and with dr. Abdullah but I met
with the security leaders I met with
mullah Bharata in Doha every one of them
understands that that this isn't going
to be resolved on the ground with guns
and mortars this is going to be resolved
through a political process and it is
time for that political process to begin
with all the Afghans coming together
around the table I'm still optimistic
that we can get there the time is of the
essence immediately there are thoughts
in Congress to hold China responsible
for the corona virus outbreak because it
had information and they called on China
to pay damages to the US and the world
are you planning is the administration
planning to sue China or to ask China to
compensate and on Syria the State
Department has asked the regime to
release prisoners you are citizens among
them are you planning to put any
pressure on the regime in case they
didn't your second question we have
asked a series to release all those that
are wrongfully detained not only
Americans but others as well
we've called on the Islamic Republic of
Iran to do the same we think in this
time where there is enormous health risk
to these individuals that on a purely
humanitarian basis forget the other
reasons that it would be it is that they
are in the first instance wrongfully
detained we think this would be a good
opportunity for him to make a
humanitarian assistance and allow these
Americans to return home to their
families with respect to the first time
I'll leave to Congress I I'm not doing
that anymore I'll leave to Congress to
decide how they want to proceed but as I
said earlier today it's not the day for
recriminations and accountability we
need to make clear that the information
that is available to everyone in the
world is available that it means full
transparency by everyone including by
the Chinese Communist Party this is a
continuing challenge we still need good
information from the Chinese Communist
Party about what has taken place there
and the level of the virus that
continues inside of that country we need
accurate transparent information just
like we're demanding from every country
around the world but there'll be a right
time after we've managed to address this
crisis after we've managed to get these
economies back on their feet
there'll be a time for the world to
evaluate responsibility for what took
place thank you all very much ever
heaven have a great day
you